Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie. We just found out about a bunch
of deleted scenes in Thor 11 Thunder featuring
Galactus some X-Men deleted scenes so we'll break
it all down there was even an alternate ending to
the movie with Lena Headey's character I'll explain
who she was supposed to play if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos they actually just posted a trailer
for a lot of the big stuff coming up in the first
half of next year like the secret Invasion trailer
Loki season 2 trailer I just did a big breakdown
video of that so I'll post a link for it at the
end of this and down in the description below but
recently you've probably seen that Marvel has been
dropping more deleted scenes and stuff that was
taken out of Thor love and thunder and it was huge
usually with movies that have a lot of deleted
scenes you joke that there's like a whole other
movie Inside the movie that they actually released
but there's like 10 different movies inside Thor
11 Thunder with all the different ideas that they
had recently one of the Marvel artists that worked
on the movie revealed that Natalie Portman's
Jane Foster Mighty Thor was going to be fighting
a version of Galactus fing Fang fume it could
have been the world serpent as well and the same
gargantos shumogorth looking creature sure that
was in Doctor Strange too Multiverse of Madness
so it did seem like at one point they had planned
to have some more Crossover with Doctor Strange to
maybe some of the other Marvel movies and because
this is a huge deal literally and metaphorically
like you have a lot of huge monsters Galactus
literally huge what was originally going to
happen is that we were going to see Jane Foster's
Mighty Thor Adventures on Earth while Thor was
busy with the Guardians of the Galaxy before he'd
come back to earth so like Jane Foster's Thor vs
Galactus would have happened during a completely
different part of the movie and I think it's easy
to understand why they got rid of this part of
the movie because there are so many big characters
that they're just burning through super quickly as
a sort of jokey kind of way the way they actually
cut the movie in the final version that we saw on
screen is a little misleading like when Thor comes
back for the first time it seems like it hasn't
been that long but in actuality a good amount
of time has passed and Jane Foster has been Thor
wielding mule near for a good long while they just
didn't do a very good job of explaining the big
time Jump between her getting the hammer and then
Thor coming back to New Asgard you have to imagine
her battling all these different characters like
fing Fang Foom schumagorth Galactus being like a
six seven hour version of the movie which would
be great I'd love to see a seven hour Marvel
movie but the other obvious big reason why
they probably didn't want to include Galactus
in the final version of the movie is because
they're saving him for like Marvel phase seven
we might see some teasers for him during Marvel
phase six but I'm not expecting him to be like a
huge character metaphorically or literally during
the new Fantastic Four movie or at least the
first Fantastic Four movie maybe in the sequels
the other big Galactus deleted scene is also
connected to an X-Men deleted scene where they go
to omnipotent City because there was meant to be
hundreds and hundreds of gods all over the place
everywhere you look from all different parts of
the comics when they come to get Zeus's help and
they sort of pan around the room they feature a
bunch of different groups of gods but if you look
at this scene here zoom and enhance it depicts
one of the sections of the godhead you know around
this big chamber here that they featured in the
background of all these scenes like I said there
are countless sections each of them having this
many gods in each section so there probably way
way more deleted scenes and Easter eggs of Gods
like this zoom and enhance we'll start with the
biggest ones here like there are obviously many
many gods here this is their version of Galactus
who looks very much like old school Galactus
very purple from the comics and look right next
to him this isn't the Juggernaut himself this
is meant to be sidorak The God Who Juggernaut
gets his powers from and The God Who Doctor
Strange's Crimson bands of sidorax spell came
from when he was using it in Avengers Infinity war
against Thanos they also call this item during the
first Doctor Strange movie that they used to
trap kycilius in the Crimson bands of sidorak
foreign
the reason why they call both of them the
Crimson bands of ciderack is because one
of them is a spell based on cedarak's Power and
one of them is a relic imbued with ciderax power
kind of like the Crimson Gem of sidorak where
Juggernaut gets his powers from the sacred gem
shall prepare himself to receive the power of the
Crimson fans of ciderac there are a ton of other
gods here too like over to the right you see a
version of Hercules just sitting right next to
them this actually looks kind of like a version
of Aries over here too there were a bunch of
other Greek gods like we saw a version of Athena
actually in the movie we saw a version of Dionysus
but there were many other agree gods that they
didn't include I'll talk about those other deleted
scenes at the end of the video though but like we
did see a version of Hercules show up at the end
of the movie in the post-credits scene where Zeus
declared war on Thor and the asgardians and sent
him to kill him that wasn't meant to be another
Avengers 5 King Dynasty incursions or Secret Wars
teaser that was a teaser for something more like
a war of the Realms type of event that they might
do is like another mini Avengers crossover movie
like Captain America 4 New World Order is like a
mini Avengers crossover movie Civil War is another
good example of that like a Thor based movie where
he's like the main character where you have a ton
of other crossover characters in a winds up being
more of a war of the Gods War of the Realms
literally situation in but talking more about
Galactus early on I'd actually wondered if they
teased characters like Silver Surfer or Galactus
through Thor love and thunder somehow because old
school Thor encountered Galactus a bunch of times
encountered Silver Surfer a bunch of times it
looks like they had a plan to do that initially
I think because Galactus is a big part of the
end of the gore of the god butcher storyline in
the comics so the comic book version of Gore the
god butcher very different in the way that Thor
fought him and defeated him later in that timeline
after they defeated Gore the necro sword continues
to exist in this sort of void but at the end of
this timeline you have a much older version of
Thor and it's basically Earth slowly dying its
last breath like it's one of the last remaining
living planets there are no other planets for
Galactus to feed on so he comes for Earth and it
becomes basically Thor versus Galactus Thor using
the necrosaur to try and defeat Galactus but it's
happening in the future of that timeline so I
think it's pretty easy to assume why they didn't
want to actually include Galactus in the movie
like we'll just get rid of this and include him
in some later storyline slightly different version
of the character because one you you also had to
kind of explain why he's there like there's this
whole explainer that you have to add on top of all
the crazy stuff that's going on during the movie
also showing off his physical appearance looking
like this kind of blocks them into this version
of Galactus too and I think the version that we'll
wind up seeing in the MCU eventually will look
a little bit different what they might wind up
doing long term though is just because Galactus
is such a big concept they might leave him for
Marvel phase seven like he could be part of the
next Saga after the Multiverse Saga we're also
not going to get the Fantastic Four movie to the
beginning of Marvel phase six and it makes sense
that they would want to wait to include them first
in the MC like the new versions whichever those
are going to be and then bring in Silver Surfer
and Galactus and because they did that in the fox
Marvel movies Kevin feige said their big thing is
doing a version that we haven't seen before like
doing something with the characters we haven't
seen before and that means not just going straight
back to Silver Surfer and Galactus so it sounds
like when they do introduce those characters in
the MCU like it'll be a slightly different version
of Galactus with a slightly different backstory
bringing the sidorak character in the MCU would
ALS also brought its own challenges with it like
canonizing more X-Men mutants related stuff which
they're doing right now like it makes sense that
they want to introduce more X-Men characters when
people think of the Juggernaut though they mostly
think of that funny X-Men the Last Stand scene
introducing the character don't you know who I am
the juvenile [__] I still laugh every time I see
that Vinnie Jones clip Juggernaut was also a big
character during Deadpool 2 we know that Deadpool
is coming into the MCU so technically that would
canonize that version of Juggernaut to the MCU
when they cross over the funny thing about this
version of Juggernaut too is that even though he
does look way more comic book accurate like he's
huge like comic book Juggernaut he's actually
voiced by Ryan Reynolds himself like they just
changed his voice a little bit if you listen
really carefully you can kind of pick out Ryan
Reynolds in there somewhere I'm gonna rip you in
half now Juggernaut is Professor X's stepbrother
they did a version of his origin story during
X-Men the Animated Series there were multiple
alternate endings to the movie like there was
no one alternate ending there were a bunch of
different versions of the ending at one point
this one was titled stealing Thunder and it was
Thor meaning a version of this woman here who I
believe is meant to be Lena heady's character she
was going to play a version of Hera Zeus's wife
during the movie like during the movie Zeus is a
big character they make a bunch of jokes about
him they show you Hercules in the post-credits
scene but you know ever actually see Hera in the
movie because she was played by Lena Headey she
filmed a bunch of these scenes for the ending and
it looks like she's having a very Sinister ending
scene with Thor and I think this was meant to
be part of the movie when Zeus was actually
portrayed as a more good benevolent character you
may have seen some of the Zeus deleted scenes from
completely different parts of the movie where Zeus
like legitimately just gives Thor his lightning
bolt instead of him stealing it during the movie
like a completely different plot for what Zeus
was supposed to do oh power comes from the heart
like a Romans say a pre-alcore open your heart
yes paternity is at the edge of space
you go and you go until you can't go no
further there you will find the altar of
Eternity Thunderbolt will take you there sure you
won't come with us we can really use the king of
the Gods no no no no to go there you must be
pure Zeus is many things but he's not pure
whole different vibe of the character like he
tries to help Thor teach him some lessons and
send him on his way to go fight Gore the god
butcher whereas during the theatrical cut they
portray Zeus as more of a bad character who wants
to kill Thor at the end of the film so I think
in this alternate ending Hera was supposed
to get that plot and she was going to set
up this big Hercules post-credits scene where
he then goes after Thor to try and kill him I
know a lot of you are also asking if a version
of Loki is ever going to run into a version of
Thor again that's what secret Wars is for stuff
like that we'll see if there's any kind of Thor
Cameo during Loki season 2 like we had frog
Thor during Loki season one who was actually
voiced by Chris Hemsworth he actually did the
grunts for frog Thor everyone click here for
my Loki season 2 trailer video that they just
released and click here for my frog Thor video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!